so let me let me do this let me let me
pull up this story and give you a really
good example
we have this story from foxnews.com va
tech swimmer rip's ncaa transgender
participation policy feels like the
final spot was taken from me
rekha guy orgy
i'm not trying to do that i just i'm
like i don't know missed the cut for the
consolation final in the 500 free at the
uh at ncaa championships so um this this
swimmer uh hit uh ranked 17th and thus
was booted out of the finals and then
issued a statement saying it's not fair
because leah thomas who won first place
is a biological male and that's why she
got bumped
i'll tell you why i take issue with this
and it exemplifies what i was just
saying a moment ago i was explaining how
the the culture war right doesn't stand
up or better a better way to put it is
the middle the the not super political
individuals who are just working and
living their lives don't stand up so you
were your sense a moment ago that you
know regular people out there in the
world are probably closer to the middle
you know but they have lives and jobs
the people at this in the in this uh
competition the ncaa uh women's league
apparently it's been reported privately
are all outraged that a biological male
is competing against biological females
but not a single one of them publicly
comes out and says
i am upset about this i do not feel it
is right to have me compete in the
situation they could at the very least
say i am issuing a protest to the fact
that we are being told we have to
compete against a biological male but i
will swim they could do that they won't
even do that and it it only after
the one person who just got bumped by
one slot loses
do they come out and say this is unfair
here's why i find this fascinating where
is the person who got 18th
why aren't they complaining and speaking
up oh because it didn't matter they
would not have won whether if if lyia
thomas was removed they'd be 17th they
still would not have made the finals
why isn't the person who's in 16th
complaining they made the finals what do
they care right the person who got 17th
was bumped by one space and they've got
a scapegoat for what's upsetting them
now if people in the middle actually did
care about this and apparently like look
behind the scenes a letter was issued
parents have been complaining
if they if they don't speak up and stand
up what they actually believe in and are
worried about then they're just going to
lose
and
what am i supposed to do just assume
their feelings and speak up for them i
mean i will
but this is the main issue right now
this is a left ideological position that
a biological male is competing against
females this leah thomas is six foot
four broad shoulders much much larger
than all of the other women was actually
i think ranked number eight in the men's
division now a lot of people are posting
uh a meme showing that leah thomas was
ranked 462 or whatever that was after
hormone replacement therapy knocked leah
thomas to the bottom of the rankings
and then
everyone started saying look it's a
bottom ranked male actually um before
transitioning was actually one of the
top ranked males
and now is the number one female but my
point is this if you're in the middle
and you're not paying attention you're
not speaking up
this is what this is what's happening
these people privately are complaining
about it okay well if i know they're mad
at least we consume they are they're
gonna lose everything these young women
are not to win gold ever again and it's
their own faults for not standing up and
actually issuing a complaint about
what's going on so here's the issue i
have with people not standing up for
women's sports they specifically asked
for a women's division i remember
learning about title ix in high school
that was quite a while ago but that's at
the point um and i remember thinking
okay i think it's cool that women have
their own division that they can compete
in that they're only competing against
other women awesome if you fought for
something like that you need to defend
it and women are highly agreeable i see
women just going along to get along but
i tweeted earlier and i firmly believe
that if women don't stand up against
this if women don't refuse to swim with
this um
false swimmer they deserve to lose 100
percent they just they deserve to lose
all the time they deserve no more gold
medals ever they don't deserve their own
league because if you're not going to
stand up for what whoever came before
you fought for then you clearly don't
think it's important you don't think
your scholarship is important i i gotta
i gotta add
many of the women in this league have
actually spoken up in defensively at
thomas really yes 100
and even in this woman uh rekha gyorgy
oh yeah she actually stated in her
complaint i fully stand with and respect
leah thomas she's no different from the
rest of us who wake up every day and
train hard it's like okay
i i i think to be completely honest and
i mean this legitimately rekka is only
complaining because she lost and she got
bumped and she has a scapegoat i think
you're right and this is exactly a case
of women being too agreeable you can't
give someone a foothold like that you
can say i respect them as an athlete
fine but they should never compete
against other women but why are you why
are you assuming they're opposed
if they publicly say they're for leah
thomas why would anyone assume they're
opposed to it well they wrote the letter
you know they talk behind the scenes you
know we really don't like be in the
locker room with this
guy
and i'm it's it's it's obvious that this
makes him uncomfortable and they know
there's something wrong but they're not
saying i will not swim with him so we'll
operate under that premise behind the
scenes we have seen letters issued by
the parents complaining saying their
daughters are upset
and they feel like you know they're
being cheated or whatever okay well the
issue is
if publicly they won't fight for it
they lose it yeah so we're operating the
assumption they're upset it's all
happening but these are the regular
people who are working or going to
school deep down many of them know
they're being slighted being wrong
they're upset but they won't do anything
about it so
what do we do
look to caitlyn jenner one of the sages
of our time if you're going to talk to
anybody about transgender in sports
caitlyn jenner is the person who used to
be bruce jenner biological male
transitioned to caitlyn bruce was an
olympic athlete i think he won gold
medals i think so yeah he was like super
famous
yeah yeah of course the father in um the
kardashians now's transition caitlyn
jenner and speaks out against this not
says i have the balls to stand up for
women and girls in sports yes
katelyn jenner actually said i have the
key
right now i retweeted it
she says that she's not about to stand
up for transgender rights she's here to
protect women's sports that's the point
and transgender rights yeah you're going
to get transgender rights but women in
sports and women's sports is a unique it
needs to be protected i think that
kaitlyn is a perfect person to speak out
about this because caitlyn used to
compete at the olympic level and then
transitioned to try to be more feminine
so here let's look at the tweet oh my
gosh caitlyn jenner was responding to
pink news who said caitlyn jenner
launches another disgraceful attack on
trans athletes without a hint of irony
and caitlyn jenner said no i just had
the balls to stand up for women and
girls in sports
and i didn't believe that tweet was real
no yeah and a bunch of other people were
responding to screenshots of it saying
there's no way that's real that's real
but
it's real yeah yeah so anyway look i
don't i don't know
you know going back to what we were
saying before in the previous
conversation about um
just everything that's been going on in
the culture war
if most people are upset about what's
happening and feel like they're in the
middle ground but
none of them actually speak up then it's
just going to get worse i would even say
that that's proof that they're caitlyn
jenner is part of the middle ground
yeah oh absolutely
yeah yeah absolutely she probably
disagrees with somebody like ben shapiro
on the daily wire and certain trans
issues but she also obviously disagrees
with the idea of of uh who's you know
biological somebody was born as a
biological man competing with a
biological woman in a sport but i think
i think the issue is that um
what we would refer to as the right in
the culture war incorporates post
liberal all the way to to
far right actually so you have this
massively eclectic group of people with
varying different opinions caitlyn
jenner would absolutely be considered on
the right uh blair white who's trans is
considered right wing right um you know
well who else jimmy dore they call him a
leftist with an asterisk because they're
like he he he's well sure he's a
socialist but you know he just espouses
right-wing talking points so he's
right-wing so so the issue is
what caitlyn jenner would be
i mean it is called right wing
so they're not part of the left-wing
argument in in in this in in the
cultural debate the the middle ground
if you're actually talking about how
people feel the middle ground is
right-wing so that's another reason why
i would say there's no middle because if
you come out and say like me for
instance i say i support progressive
taxes admittedly i think it's a problem
just to take money give to the
government but i think income inequality
is a huge problem i think systemic
racism is a problem i'm pro-choice
they would say i'm still right-wing even
if i hold those positions are clearly
um social left you know right right now
i mean we'll get into this story in a
second about dave rubin and
conservatives but
if i say things that are clearly
economically left in social lift doesn't
matter
because my view of the world or my ideas
on civil libertarianism don't sync up
with the left they would say it's right
wing so then if if if my positions are
not in the middle then what's what's the
middle it depends on where you're
standing yeah it's all relative
yeah
no idea no it's i think it's intended to
be obfuscatively uh confusing
well the issue is that the left the far
left is controlling all the institutions
so in a perfect world we could just
ignore all of this and say well 99 of
people are in what would be considered
the middle by the far left they're not
really right they just don't agree with
the far left there's a meme about
national power
there's a meme the political compass
where the top authoritarian left says
the left and everything else is far
right yeah is it the left that controls
every institution or sir or would it be
uh neoliberal kind of people like would
you consider somebody like sergey brin
you know somebody you know the ceo of
apple or the ceo of google or the ceo of
facebook are those leftists or are those
people who are more neo-liberal who will
tweet the right thing at certain times
but never actually stand by so the so
the issue is
when we're speaking about
at least when we do you know it's hard
to you do we have to define our words
here on this show
the left includes leftists and
neoliberal establishments and the reason
the reason is that the leftists tend to
align with support or vote for the
neoliberals um biden being a good
example so i'll i'll say contra points
for instance is a prominent trans woman
and leftist youtuber but made a video
saying you have to vote for joe biden
that being the case you'll see many of
these people like uh on the left like
vosh we've had in the show
will call me a conservative he clearly
sees himself contrasted with me even
though he comes on the show and we like
we agree on certain things granted he's
been accused of harboring very abhorrent
you know views himself whatever what he
believes is is entirely unto himself the
issue is that
it's more like it's like what matters
most is tribe not principle or fact so i
can come out and be like i think donald
trump represents the worst of american
culture
but i certainly think he was the better
choice to vote for whereas the left is
like we don't care about all of the
corruption we've complained about three
years ago with hillary clinton we're
gonna vote for joe biden anyway or they
make up some reason to hate donald trump
or
leftists who you know agree with the
mainstream media's narratives even
though they've been lied to 800 times in
the past 10 minutes so it's at at that
point like you can you can see the
distinction between the spheres of
influence
there's a bunch of different ways to
define the different factions but you
know in the right you have people who
are skeptical and discerning of news and
demanding of facts and on the left you
have the media report at this time so it
must be true oh that was wrong but this
one the media reported so it must be
true are they because i've seen a lot of
right-wing facebook people that i know
and they don't seem very discerning of a
lot of the garbage that gets posted on
facebook yeah i mean if we're talking
about regular layman you're going to see
a mixed bag of people who believe random
nonsense i'll just get i get a lot of
news articles in my comments or somebody
say hey check this out look at this and
then i'll check out the article and i'll
say oh that's a lot of interesting stuff
that they didn't cite and then i'll
google it and it'll just all be this but
but yes but i'll clarify too i
specifically mean like among the the the
leaders of you know uh
you know talking sharing ideas writing
articles you'll see on the left they
repeatedly fall for every single hoax
the right certainly does fall for some
you know we had this conversation last
week but i can go through the whole list
of every black lives matter protest that
turned out to be a false narrative like
trayvon martin michael brown uh ahmed
arby's a really good example just over
and over and over again then you can
look at the covington kids you can look
at jesus malette you can look at
russiagate ukraine gate all of these
stories prove to be false the laptop
being the most egregious the issue is
when you have leftists and neoliberals
either pretending to believe or
genuinely believing stories that keep
getting proven false i think trayvon
martin and uh jesse smolet would be
different categories altogether one is
an area of fun of somewhat disagreement
on how something should have gone and
the other was i just made this up
well no no no trayvon martin was the
media edited
the fight 911
from george zimmerman to make it seem
like oh it's okay that's what it is
you're talking about also where they
made george zimmerman look whiter by
photoshopping him yeah so what i mean is
that people keep falling for me i
understand for that yeah the the
corporate press will put out a lie and
then one group of people just says
that's true and then six months later
they're like well it was wrong but this
story is true i remember seeing when
they when they edited the way that he uh
looked when they edited as his facial
collar that was kind of aggravating well
they they edited the the 9-1-1 call
where the 9-1-1 operator asked his race
they cut that part out so it sounded
like he was just saying he's suspicious
looking because he's you know he's black
but what really happened was he said he
looked suspicious and they said how tall
is he he's like five ten and what's he
wearing he's wearing a hoodie and what's
his race i think he's black they edited
all that out so uh michael brown hands
up don't shoot now you have don't say
gay just media live after media after
media alignment and and these people
just keep believing it at a certain
point i have to say they're probably not
believing it they're probably just lying
the problem with doing things like that
that erodes people's trust is that
they're willing to go to the other side
and the other side can lie to them as
much as they want because they have
gotten
because they just don't like this side
as much as they do and it happens people
who just all of a sudden are like my
political belief is now you know been
swayed because i'm hearing an argument
from someone who's been honest to me
about these other issues once somebody's
honest to you about these things that
you've been lied to it's very easy for
that person to lie to you about
everything else and for you to be less
critical and then for the pendulum to
swing in the other direction and go back
and forth yeah so you know the way i see
it is at a certain point people will see
like 10 stories in the mainstream press
that are all lies and then they'll turn
to a conservative and say tell me the
truth and they'll say well you know
those things are lies right okay now
this was a truth you know here's the
truth here and they'll say okay i
believe you
because i i have no i don't know who
else to trust right if you if you're tr
honest to me about these issues you're
probably honest about this one and so
you know ultimately therein lies the big
problem which is
the middle ground
i guess the right are people who just
don't trust the establishment anymore
yeah that one way to put it yeah it's
like the media reports and you're like i
don't believe it
you know i kind of see it a little bit
more as weak-minded people and
strong-minded people uh you get
weak-minded people on any any side
extreme leftist extremities people that
just buy the bull
and that's the matter not everyone's
always weak-minded sometimes
strong-minded people become weak-minded
because a bad diet not enough sleep
stress sometimes weak-minded people get
strong-minded because adversity they
they struggle through adversity
but that's that's more of a category as
i split these people thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you